hey there nerds
like fans this is the inaugural episode
my new series bad comic art now as you
know comics that have been around for a
very long time and in order to make the
beautiful medium what it is hundreds
upon thousands of artists are required
to come along and draw till their eyes
believe for our enjoyment there are a
ton of amazing artists out there and a
ton of not-so-great ones
and both are liable to put out at least
one shitty drawing here and there it's
not the easiest job in the world
sometimes they have strict deadlines and
cut a corner or two just to get it done
faster sometimes their distinctive art
style just clashes with an established
design and the result is a mess maybe
they just happen to be an artist from
the 90s it was brought in because all
the good artists decide to leave Marvel
and DC to start their own thing with
arguable success whatever the case
sometimes you as a reader are just
ripped out of the story by a really
awful piece of art we're going to give
our thoughts and suggestions from bad
art we found I've scoured countless
forums and blogs to pick out some really
uh well art is a loose term for a reason
exceptional with me is our good friend
David who spurred this idea by sending
me tons of bad comic art that he found
which we made fun of for hours so I
thought why not make that a series how
are you doing today David um fine that
this is bit this comic book thing is
basically the equivalent of making fun
of bad grammar in a story and I've done
that before and it is so much fun
yeah um one of the favorite pictures of
mine that you sent is that Rob Liefeld
picture of Franklin Richards
that isn't that your profile picture on
facebook now yeah it is okay um to begin
we have a piece from artist rags Morales
from Action Comics number 11 where to
begin well Superman clearly isn't seeing
eye to eye with the flash
I'm sure this moment would have been
more emotional without this sort of face
just slap a beanie hat on him and he
looks like the kind of guy that would
try to trademark reaction videos on
YouTube Wow what
this like his eyes just drift apart in
fear alone or something like that now
it's always confused me out how art like
this slips past to print especially
considering the dialogue next to it I
mean it doesn't take a rocket scientist
this that to see that these don't line
up it was a deadline thing I think yeah
now it probably wasn't that hard as a
pencil ER to go back and erase those two
black dots and make new ones and then it
probably wouldn't be that hard for the
colorist to go and fix it as they add
all the depth to it the badness of this
is really really very subtle but to me
it's a lot more fun if I imagined that
it was intentional and that is like
Superman is just going like this and
he's so whacked out of his mind on a
chemical or substance or something
he's just saying random bits of nonsense
like what this these captions are these
captions are totally pretentious so
Superman's on like a bad drug trip yeah
and he's just saying these things like
they're the most imaginative discoveries
ever invented by anyone it's like he
started standing there just sort of
swaying slowly backwards and forwards
while saying these random things and
then Batman is scanning his blood to
detect foreign chemicals and Green
Lantern is just laughing his head off
while Diana Diana is politely turning
the other way and flash is just sort of
nodding awkwardly trying to get away and
keeps walking towards him saying vaguely
poetic nonsense but that's a lot more
fun than this sort of minor mystic yeah
just like paint a whole new scene based
on what we're not seeing here like
everyone else in the Justice League is
very concerned for his mental health
yeah now a point I wanted to bring back
is that colorist can add a lot to
drawings if they put the time into it
then again there are examples of
colorists who made the art considerably
worse
the prequel tie-in comic for the game
injustice gods among us by the same
title has become infamous for some
hilarious art the problem stemmed from
this book being released on a weekly
basis digitally an artist David Garden
gave us this masterpiece
oh he's punching the punching the one
thing hunting I can't tell uh I looked
at one of the earlier panels from this
and I think it's some kind of like
training post it's it's it's like it's
like the the color of his blood and like
the his fist sort of mixed together with
whatever that thing is and it can't tell
now that even his fist it looks weird
and huge it's the perspective is strange
like Batman's eyes
Batman's big blue eyes look pasted over
his lower eyelids and the angle looks
excruciating and like he looks like he's
in pain his teeth he must be Batman must
be getting a Batman must be knocking out
a lot of his teeth and then those must
be replaced with implants that are like
from a horse or a beaver or something he
looks like you want he looks like he
wanted to get away with sleeping in
class and ask Superman to come draw
those eyelids on with a sharpie he has
oversized novelty horse teeth stuffed
into his mouth to accentuate his comical
prankster persona that he's so well
known for and also I have to comment on
this what is that what is that that
sound caption what what kind of Pope is
is it are you supposed to say that good
it also seems that his mask in face are
one color away from being the same thing
and it must take a team of eight people
and some Vaseline to remove it from his
head
it looks fused to his body like like
there's no there's there's a line
separating where his skin ends in the
suit begins it looks so uncomfortable
but it's supposed to be a helmet so to
be clear this isn't the work of David
yard him it's the work of his colorist
who clearly rushed through this without
looking closely enough let's not be too
rough on LeBeau Underwood though this
whole issue had to be done and released
in a week David yard and later went back
and recolored the entire page himself
when it was released in stores in a
printed format well it looks better I
mean I can do it every us definitely
yeah there's a lot more definition
between the PO
wisten is first and it still looks
really weird and also ours eyes closed
yes his is always eyes were closed that
looks nicely weird his eyes were closed
and then in the other image he drew them
on oh that makes more sense but his
teeth still look really weird although
they look better they look smaller yeah
and then there's actually kind of a
definition between his face and his mask
and and they still have the thud sound
then the pole is this it makes up the
good what I don't know the artist yard
and should definitely consider himself
lucky that he got to go back and fix his
butchered work later on not many comic
artists are as lucky when something they
turn out is equally as horrifying
speaking of horror let's talk about one
of my favorite artists
Arthur SOI damn I've met him at Denver
Comic Con and I even have some of his
artwork hanging up hanging up in my
basement he's known for taking a new
approach and adding a certain dark and
visceral look to a lot of other artists
work his covers for Marvel Zombies and
Walking Dead or spectacular but like any
good artist he isn't going to draw a
winner every time like this image from
the cover of Wolverine number 60 this is
amazing getting away from the main
attraction I'd like to note that his
victim here seems very nonchalant about
being stabbed through the head what is
this what is this victim he's just kind
of standing there a person I don't know
I have no idea he's just kind of
standing there fragments they look like
bits of metal it is easy robot because
and why are the fragments flying off in
sort of an angle shouldn't they be
flying up straight oh well I don't
believe it's blood expelling from his
mouth but if you look at the silhouette
he gives he gives the impression that
his mouth is closed so where is all of
that blood shooting out of it's weird
also what is this guy is he a knight a
samurai why does he have goggles I
thought he was a robot dressed up like a
samurai
I mean that happened in one of the
movies maybe mm-hmm maybe um well I mean
we won't hold it against him um how
every single part of Wolverines body is
just horrendously over veined like
there's veins just everywhere what kind
of a person has these kind of huge veins
they're they're they're about as thick
as my finger uh Hugh Jackman and know
that that's impossible with the amount
of blood that people have in him in law
I mean I was I was kind of hoping you'd
write something about his facial
expression because I I have no notes for
that oh yeah what to talk about
it looks like he's either having the
derp face of a century or singing the
finishing note of Nessun Dorma from the
opera Turandot no I didn't think that
Logan was a lover of opera let her alone
a singer
his eyes were squinting they look so
joyful and happy definitely sings the
best there is at what he does in what
that is is the homage at all okay so for
the sake of variety I found a panel from
a WCW comic now wrestling has a pretty
silly lore and it's a lot of dudes and
costumes punching each other so I
imagine they thought that would work
great as a comic and boy were they wrong
this art is from the 11th issue drawn by
artist Ron Wilson who apparently forgets
how mirrors work in this image we see
sting staring into the mirror and
looking upset about the bar stool seat
that's attached to his scalp and also I
can't help but notice that the big
letter C is facing the wrong direction
in his reflection so his his eyes are
the wrong color his visor I didn't even
see that one because I'm partially
colorblind his eyes are blue in the main
picture but his eyes are brown in the
reflection what what I mean I guess it
was like a stylistic thing to make the
color so different but like even his
eyes yeah his eyes look like what his
skin is like what what color would you
say that skin is like sort of a peach
maybe in the rail one and then he's more
of like a like a urine yellow in the
reflection but okay I know drawing a
character in a mirror can't be easy but
the least you can do is make sure the
physics of a mirror work properly also
that the angle is really off to because
he's sort of looking into the mirror
from the side but it looks like he's
looking into it head-on from their flag
looks like he's taller than his
reflection yeah and I like to imagine
that this works a lot better if it isn't
actually a reflection of the guy but a
clone you know like like in sort the
Sorcerer's Apprentice when you get
trapped on the wrong side of a mirror
haha
does anybody else remember that I I'm
glad that you brought up your
interpretation of this because I said
that sting may also be having
vivid hallucinations of his evil
alternate personality maybe I haven't
read it so I'll assume that's what's
going on I'll be sleep at night and also
that if you look that the tattoos are
different on the reflection like those
little nubs that come out from the sides
they go down they go down all the way to
his mouth or the end yeah even even if
his facial expression was different that
wouldn't look like that there there is
so much wrong with this image it Wow
it's wonderful it's it's it's a this
belongs in a museum it does it belongs
in a museum
thanks Harrison Ford I can't wait for
you to be in another Indiana Jones movie
that disappoints everyone now let's top
it all off with a picture of the Caped
Crusader using his hang glider made of
stone to do midair acrobatics this art
is from Kelly Jones in Gotham after
midnight you see there is such thing as
stylizing an image too much it's clear
that style involves exaggerated
proportions and a lot of shadows but
this image is just taking it too far
Batman's leg is more than twice as thick
as his head well I guess he's been doing
a lot of squats lately with his one one
leg that with his one leg that he has
wears there's this other one if his legs
are that huge shouldn't we be able to
see at least a little of his other one
this is less the Dark Knight and more
the thing that his arm his left arms the
one that goes backward is twisted so far
back that he's either possessed by the
devil or it's broken and his right arm
goes from incredibly thick to really
really thin at the wrist it's just so
bizarre like is that glove incredibly
tight in pinching the circulation off to
his hand yeah why does his cape sit at
this angle his left arm is sticking out
of the back of it but the implication is
that he's using it to glide it's did he
rip a hole in it and the cape is
collapsing as he falls to his death ah
thank God we never let John Carpenter
direct the Dark Knight because this is
what would have
the thing what what's with those ears on
his mask they're huge
I bet he has a hard time getting through
doors with those that's good magic can
you imagine a situation where he needs
to make a dramatic entrance to a room
with the Joker and you just hear him
walking into the room and then thud then
he has to like bend down and then lean
under the doorway to get through or what
what if he tripped and fell on the Joker
he would have impaled him on his fears
any last comments um we'd better do Rob
Liefeld next we will next time I okay
I'm glad you brought that up a lot of
people are probably going to be saying
you should do Rob Liefeld art I'm under
the belief that that is too easy I mean
sure we're gonna talk about it maybe
eventually if this series goes as well
as I'm hoping and we make many parts as
I want to but like it shouldn't just be
the Rob Liefeld show it I feel like if
it was just cuz I mean there's so many
bad Rob Liefeld drawings we could
probably do an entire episode on just
that maybe we should maybe maybe there
should be a Rob Liefeld special sometime
soon um this was incredibly fun I'm glad
we got to do this um this was a very
interesting type of video because I sent
David the images beforehand and told him
to write down his list of notes about
them and I wrote down mine and then we'd
read them off to each other so he could
get some genuine reactions this was the
first time either of us had heard the
other's jokes yes
that's like there was a lot of giggling
at each other yeah I like this format
and I was worried it wouldn't go as well
as it did but um this I would say this
was a success
yeah I'd like to ask everyone watching
this to actually suggest comic art maybe
if you can find a specific panel and
link it to me in the comments or if you
just have a specific book where every
panel is terrible
it's good to give me the artist and the
look and the number so that we can
credit them for their my masterpiece
yeah yeah that alright um to close out I
wanted to David you want this to be the
official announcement this probably
won't be the official announcement but
it might be just to get it out there
yeah
David is starting his own channel I'm
not sure I'm up but probably soon I'm
just working on a debut video which I'm
very excited for he's I've seen his
script for it and it's fantastic or an
early draft of it I'd know you rewrite
things a lot I rewrote that one and
re-recorded it three times each well
Dean okay alright well to be perfect uh
whenever I get this uploaded we'll
probably have a link yeah try to get a
link in the description and we also put
a big stupid annotation over something
I'm really excited to have video working
on his stuff we've got several scripts
written out for new videos he's got a
really great big project coming out soon
and I'm waiting on the work of somebody
else but I'm very yeah we have a third
person helping us with that one
and I just I gotta say I I hope we can
do this again soon I'm going to start
trying to find images for the next one
and good luck to you with the channel so
yeah yeah alright uh what should we
close this out with um alright just
solid silence yeah